what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
from anime on program today I will be
breaking down the most recent craziness
in the black cover story including the
grand entrance of demon queen van iike
the final member of the dark triad that
we still hadn't seen in battle up to
this point the reveal of Anika and
Maggie colas overpowered magic
completely changed what we thought we
knew about the demons in black clover
and it completely reversed the progress
that we thought we had made in like the
last six chapters and as a result it
looks like things are about to get very
ugly for the heroes on top of that Noel
is finally going to go face to face with
her mother's alleged murderer which is
something that we've all been waiting
for
so let's get into it if you enjoy the
black clover content on this channel you
want us to keep it go and please leave a
like to let me know it really does help
and if you happen to be new to anime
uproar please don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications a big thank you to
all of our anime upper patrons who make
videos like this one possible especially
now with the current global crisis I
will talk more about patreon at the end
of this video but first please be
advised that this video will of course
contain black clover manga spoilers I
will be referencing the very latest
developments in the story so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned
first off I want to give some quick
praise to the cover for chapter 2 5 1 it
features char me as Little Red Riding
Hood and her food magic wolf as the wolf
from that story and then there's a star
randomly in the background looking like
a Bavarian lumberjack I definitely
appreciate this cover after the previous
chapter in which we got to see char me
using her food magic again so thanks
Tabata very cool this chapter starts off
with Gaia the spirit guardian who uses
true lightning magic taking down another
one of Anika's dark disciples apparently
even though the other dark disciples
were able to defeat the other spirit
Guardians Gaia is in a league of his own
so he was able to
dispatch this dark disciple without any
help from the clover kingdom mages
beaver girl Noel and mimosa are relieved
to see that all of the dark disciples
have now been defeated
thanks to Gaia char me leo and luck
Laura Pacheco is especially impressed
with the performance of the clover
kingdom mages despite being weaker than
the dark disciples on paper they were
able to grow and evolve during their
respective battles and this allowed them
to come out victorious in the end even
though the odds were stacked against
them I've also been thinking about this
recently and it really does seem that
the combination of clover kingdom magic
and Hart Kingdom magic really allowed
some of our favorite clover kingdom
mages to get much stronger very quickly
when they boost their own magic with the
rune magic from the Hart Kingdom they
are able to reach new heights in ways
that they never could before this is how
I was personally rationalizing the fact
that the clover kingdom Manges became so
much stronger during the time skip and
of course that is how I was
rationalizing the fact that they were
able to defeat the dark disciples I
figured that the unique blend of clover
Kingdom and Hart Kingdom magic gave them
that extra edge that the dark disciples
simply couldn't account for
however the celebrations about all of
these victories are quickly cut short as
yet another dark disciple bursts into
the very space where Laura Pacheco Noel
and mimosa are located this depraved
dark disciple is using some sort of
weird tongue magic and he talks about
being able to sense the magic of hot
young girls this dude definitely isn't
shy or worried about looking like a sick
pervert in front of strangers in fact a
sick pervert seems to be exactly what
this guy is but it appears that the
girls were expecting this enemy and
mimosa quickly dispatches him using an
offensive magic spell called planned
creation magic magic cannon flower it
seems that this spell was able to
channel some of lo topa chicas power
into the attack itself and the dark
disciple appears to have been one shot
at by mimosa after getting hit he is
just lying motionless on the ground his
massive tongue hanging from his mouth
but in the very next moment
Vanek a herself of
peers through the same hole in the wall
that her dark disciple had created the
final member of the dark triad Wanaka
the eyepatch wearing demon queen is here
and she greets Laura Pacheco in a
friendly and almost joyful way
Vanek assess that the last time they met
she just cursed Laura Pacheco for Miggy
Kula and went home but this time she is
ready to go all out she's ready to have
all the fun that she wants from what
Wanaka says here it seems that Miggy
Kula specifically wanted to curse Laura
Pacheco but not kill her I wonder why
that is why is it that Miggy Kula was so
interested in cursing beaver girl in
particular but not actually killing her
I am sure that this is something that is
going to be covered in the very near
future if you asked me to personally
guess I'm thinking that maybe Meggie
Kula can curse people and then slowly
absorb their magic and feed on it over a
period of time this then makes Miggy
Kula progressively stronger while slowly
killing Miggy Kulas victims know else
face instantly contorts as she sees
vantika Wanaka is of course the host for
Miggy Kula the very demon who is
believed to have killed
Noelle's mother and this is one of the
reasons why I really want to know why
Miggy Kula curse the beaver girl when we
find that out we might also find out
what happened to OCA Silva and why at
this point
Laura Pacheco asks vantika why she
decided to attack the entire heart
kingdom in various separate locations if
she was primarily after her
I mean why attack places where innocent
people live and are gonna get hurt if
she could have just come here in the
first place vanna corresponds with a
classic yawn that a smile and she says
that this way Laura Pacheco was more
likely to be into the fight
I guess what she means is that this way
bieber girl was more likely to take
Manica seriously and to take her on
herself
in person noel is furious when she hears
this type of blatant disregard for
innocent lives and noel declares that
all of Anika's henchmen are down and she
is the only one left so she better get
ready but in what is a pretty major
twist in the story
Vanek adjust shrugs and says that no you
didn't deal with them in the very next
moment the tongue-lashing dark disciple
gets up and thanks vantika
for making him feel good again meanwhile
the girls are shocked to see that the
dark disciple has gotten up since he
appeared to be completely out cold just
a moment ago as this disciple is
thanking vantika for her kindness she
casually just stomps down on him with
her foot and tells him to shut his mouth
she then tells him to hurry up and take
care of the losers who are not Laura
Pacheco because Bieber girl is hoove
Anika is primarily interested in the
dark disciple actually screams out with
pleasure and begs vantika to step on him
some more
Wow just wow can you be any more of a
simp as I said on Twitter the other day
Vanek ah has so many simps out there in
the spade Kingdom that she should
seriously consider selling jars of demon
girl bathwater Faneca then reveals that
thanks to the curse that she has placed
on her disciples no matter how many
times they are killed they will not
actually die and just as vantika says
this it is revealed that all the dark
disciples that we have met so far how
bet Simkin and all the rest have all
recovered and are back in top fighting
shape all the enemies that our heroes
spent like the last half dozen chapters
defeating are back on their feet and
it's as if nothing happened all of the
clover kingdoms mages hard work was for
nothing the people of the heart kingdom
are shocked and terrified but the clover
kingdom mages are not discouraged
Leo luck and charm II scream out bring
it on as mimosa Noel and Laura Pacheco
prepare to take on vantika
and her tongue-twisting disciple wanaka
then reveals that unless they can take
her down all of her disciples will just
keep coming back they cannot be defeated
and that means that the people of the
Hart Kingdom and the clover kingdom
mages were fighting them are in grave
danger and that is how this awesome
chapter ends and we are left stunned at
the revelation that demon queen wanaka
is far more overpowered than we even
realized i did not see this coming I
always knew that vantika would be way
stronger than her disciples all the
members of the dark triad are extremely
overpowered but I didn't
thing that she would be able to keep
reviving all of her dark disciples over
and over again which effectively renders
all of the progress made in the last
half dozen chapters pretty much
meaningless
what type of curse magic is this anyway
some sort of necromancy that doesn't
allow her disciples to die obviously
curses are a major part of Meggie colas
magic the demon cursed Noelle's mother
Laura Pacheco and apparently even Vanek
his own disciples have been cursed
but that curse seemingly makes them
stronger by allowing them to keep
getting up no matter how badly they are
beaten but other than this general idea
of powerful curses we still don't know
how exactly Vanek on Meggie colas magic
works and we have no idea as to the
limits of their power I assume that
there is a lot more going on here beyond
just curses and I can only imagine how
powerful vantika will be if she is
forced to really go all out during this
battle and speaking of this battle bro
I am so excited that we are finally
going to see post time skip Noelle in
action and this is not just any battle
for Noelle she will be fighting her
mother's alleged murderer so she will
have all the motivation in the world -
absolutely surpass her limits also the
fact that mimosa seemed to be channeling
some of La Roca chicas magic in her own
spell at the beginning of this chapter
tells me that we are going to see some
pretty amazing combo magic from Noelle
and the water spirit on Dean in this
upcoming battle it is going to be so
epic and I can't wait to see how all of
this plays out and of course I am super
curious to find out what new powers
Noelle now possesses and what other
unique powers and ability vantika has
let me know what you guys think what
other powers and abilities do vana kind
maggie cool out potentially have perhaps
an additional magic attribute on top of
curse magic that still hasn't been
revealed to us and how strong do you
think the new Noelle is and what new
powers and spells do you think that she
might now possess definitely share your
feedback down in the comments below if
you enjoyed this video you want us to
keep it going please leave a like to let
me know it really does help and if you
happen to be new to anime uproar don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell
turn on all notifications you really
have to go through the trouble of
clicking that bell and then selecting
the option that says all if you don't do
that you're still gonna miss a lot of
our videos even if you're subscribed
that's just how YouTube works in 2020
you can also hit me up on Twitter and
Instagram at anime or I want to give a
big thank you to all of our anime opera
patrons who make videos like this one
possible a very special thank you to a
friend a a disciple of Lord Twigg o
himself and I can't forget our the one
tier patrons the ones who rise above all
other clans including Ingrid ah Allen
Adham of the world Steelers Tyson cui
Dino acquired respect Pat a heffa
Jonathan King deci D Brandon Aviles Papa
Smurf Emperor otaku and Ritchie Martinez
finally thank you also to all our pro
hero tier patrons including the one and
only Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason
Wilson Kings eldress Anatole Cassatt's
key on hell Cruz hi Sparky 65 cricket XP
Ted no Ted Joe Stanton very Gucci Alicia
ahktar on Imola 69 Jessica Calif on Dino
commune water
Bonnie parks so d'art 12 rothwyn de hora
Emperor Mitch loves anime cynical Kraken
and JCCC walk up if you enjoy our videos
and you feel that they provide value for
you please consider supporting us on
patreon even a single dollar will give
you access to our patron exclusive
discord and your name will appear in our
videos along with these legendary people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]